yeah people in solitary for 40 years 40
40 when you think that a judge would say
40 years do something weird here is it
hi I'm Nicolas booth recent TV and today
we're talking with veteran journalist
James Ridgeway over the years he's
worked for the New Republic The Village
Voice The Wall Street Journal mother
jones currently in Washington DC he's
the guy who found out that General
Motors was tailing Ralph Nader Yale
produced the great 1992 documentary feed
which showcased the behind-the-scenes
antics of would-be presidents and
candidates Jim your current project is
solitary watch calm which is dedicated
to exploring the extent and trouble with
solitary confinement in American prisons
what's the state of solitary confinement
in America well the big thing about
solitary confinement is nobody knows I
mean it's like a black site only they're
like hundreds maybe thousands of blacks
nights all over the country these are
sections of prisons whole prisons little
tiny parts of Prisons in which people
are held incommunicado right and now at
solitary watch calm the website that
kind of warehouse is your information
you've got figures up there that there's
something like 80,000 plus people that
we know of who are in some form of
solitary absolutely well a lot of people
would like to say there were a lot fewer
but if you go by you know the standard
accepted big deal institutions account
figures like this 80,000 is pretty
pretty normal
that's what they say those is the number
growing of people who are held in some
kind of solitary confinement well I
think it probably is growing and one of
the reasons for that is that a lot of
the people in solitary maybe maybe 30
percent maybe more than that are
mentally ill so you know they take
somebody who's acting out as they say in
the general population and they say well
he's not answering the guard or you know
and they put him in solitary and of
course he gets crazier and crazier like
a guy I'm writing to in upstate New York
he tried to burn the cell down to commit
and so they took him out to the local da
they rien dated him for arson gave him
more years and sent me back to the same
place it costs a lot more money I mean
your your website us that's where it
could be as much as three times to house
somebody in a solitary unit as to have
them in the general boot cost the
figures are usually $75,000 a year
against for general population maybe
$25,000 well what should be done I know
the Senate Senate subcommittee headed by
dick Durbin senator from Illinois has
just held hearings on the widespread use
of solitary confinement where is that
heading what are your what are your
preferred kind of policy solutions to
the problems posed well first of all
it's absolutely almost totally
impossible to get anywhere in the United
States on this thing because the courts
are totally lined up against changing
anything and the lawyers you know pretty
much the same mindset the government I
mean Obama says we don't torture but
this is towards a lot of this is
straight-out torture so anyway I that
you mean the practice of solitary
confinement in other settings and
international settings of why not is
either considered or approximates
torture yes the you win and and we call
it torture we call you know went on mo
and and after Afghanistan torture and we
just never look at our own stuff so what
what should be done well I mean what
should be done is to get rid of it but
what can maybe be done is to reduce the
length of time I mean there are people
in solitary for 40 years 40 40 when you
think that a judge you know state this
is in Louisiana they took tell it
corridor that look the federal judges
would say 40 years do something weird
here isn't they just go on and on with
it they'll keep people in solitary for
the end until the end of their lives and
in fact there was a big effort now to
replace the death penalty with some kind
of a penal solid solitary for life
another was an 18 year old guy
in for the rest of his life and one law
professor is arguing that he should be
made the most miserable possible human
being he received the worst food you
should receive no amenities of any kind
he said in other words the retribution
should be intense so this is a humane
alternative yes so just executing the
result of that is that some prisoners
are begging judges to kill them and so
we can find out more about this and an
ongoing ongoing news at solitary watch
calm and also look for your writings at
motherjones.com
okay well thank you James Ridgeway for
talking to reason TV today I'm Nick
Gillespie